the University of Helsinki has decided
that it will confer an honorary
doctorate on Greta Saint Greta tuna
burger now are they going to give her a
doctorate in geology are they going to
give her a doctorate in climatology
whatever that is are they going to give
her a doctorate in meteorology are they
going to give her a doctorate even in
biology no they're going to give her a
doctorate in theology because she is a
religious figure for the false religion
of environmentalism that will happen on
June 9th 2023 I have never been happier
to see somebody receive an honorary
doctorate because this honorary
doctorate proves that everything that I
and everything that you have been saying
about environmentalism and syncreta in
particular
has been true